If you chose the circle, great work. I know I have 1 part of the circle shaded
out of 5 equal parts. So, that's definitely 1/5. The second one isn't 1/4. I do
have 5 parts but they're not all equal. I have 1 of them shaded but remember,
the parts need to be equal. This one is also correct. I have 1 out of 5 pieces
and all the pieces are equally shaped. This triangle is also not correct. I do
have 1 piece shaded, but I have 1 of 4. So this one is really 1/4. This one is
also correct. I have 5 pieces of my entire rectangle and I have one of them
shaded, so 1/5. This one is also not correct. I have 5 pieces, but they're not
equally shaped. The area hasn't been divided into 5 equal pieces, so this can't
be 1/5 of the area